can you each give me five of your best
tips for getting lit at a potluck
parties want the next to drink smoke
take you to the gray room go back to get
another drink from Arthur go back at the
Grand room and didn't have a seat we
want the answer that wasn't probably
that's new tweed poor heavy oh yeah
she's going forehead
lay back grab your drink Get Set cook we
both like to win and it's fun yeah we
were counting this they were counting
this season it's a she keeping count now
yeah even it's even even the unlikely
duo returns to vh1 with a new season of
Martha and snoops potluck dinner party
but this time things are getting
competitive what do you guys making mac
and cheese with Bologna in a minute we
had one competition last year fried
chicken
who won the fried chicken I think it was
a time I know you want an occipital oh
yes Martha and Snoop are trading in
dinner parties for celebrity cook offs
you take some potato chips potato chips
you know what game what we won the array
you guys have some pretty big-name
celebrities coming on who has surprised
you the most in the kitchen well for me
it was Matthew to go with the kitchen
cookies and Jimmy Kimmel both are really
good cooks no way and I was very
surprised because Jimmy Kimmel so busy
but he was a good cook right and and but
he helped you but not me and he was
freed in the kitchen boy did he help she
helped herself as well yeah this is such
an unlikely friendship but people love
it what is one thing that you guys have
learned about each other that might
surprise people my big discovery was how
intelligent Steve was and and he knows a
lot and despite the fact that he
sometimes plays that down and it's
fooling around and dancing he knows a
lot yes here right now
forgive me
[Music]
while the duo has a pretty impressive
roster of stars for the new season
they've got more dinner party guests in
mind I want to get on with yeah wouldn't
that be great you take Michelle I take
the rock on its very correct
I like that me too I would like to watch
both of them are very competent actions
ooh yes who is one person aside from the
Obamas that you guys would love to have
at your potluck party oh I would love to
have president Trump me too
president Trump you're invited or
invited we first make him an apprentice
yep and we would see if he can make it I
have the fire button your fire
who's one person that you would never
have at your potluck party too me too
you know I would like to see Justin and
Haley beaver like a newlywed you should
call me we roasted him this is his
chance to get back at his dip back now
well j-bird got arrested he had a big
smile in his mug shot digesting you so
mother pretty when the inmates saw your
mug shot they swiped right you know
never know that reminds me when we had
Evan Ross and Ashlee Simpson oh yeah
that was beautiful
every way right like to have a couple my
class I didn't even think to ask Bieber
he should we should ask yeah hold on
Justin what you doing oh you ain't doing
nothing
how about you in your honor I'm get on
with it all right we'll see you in a
minute
[Music]